este problema es un clásico se lo van a
encontrar en casi cualquier libro de
física el problema es este si tenemos
dos masas que están unidas por una
cuerda y esta cuerda pasa por encima de
una polea cuál será la aceleración en
ambas masas en otras palabras la
aceleración de esos tres kilogramos de
masa y la aceleración de esta masa de
cinco kilogramos y si ustedes están
preguntando qué es una polea una polea
es esta parte de acá la polea es una
pieza de plástico o metal que puede
rotar normalmente tiene un canal en ella
de manera que la cuerda se coloca ahí y
lo que hace es que rota libremente por
lo que puede tornar lo que es una
tensión horizontal en una tensión
vertical del otro lado o viceversa torna
fuerzas verticales en fuerzas
horizontales y nos permite transformar
una fuerza de una dirección a otra
dirección y es para esto para lo que nos
sirven las poleas
puede girar libremente y prácticamente
no tiene masa está polea no tiene
resistencia al movimiento entonces esta
tensión de este lado va a ser igual a la
atención de este otro lado esta tensión
vertical se transforma sin diluir en la
atención horizontal por lo que estos
valores serán iguales y esto pasará si
esta polea puede moverse libremente y
tiene una masa muy pequeña por lo que no
tenga una razón de inercia por la que no
pueda girar y ese es el problema ustedes
quieren saber cuál es la aceleración en
esta masa de 3 kilogramos y en esta masa
de 5 kilogramos
y tengo que advertirles hay una forma
sencilla de hacer esto y también hay una
forma difícil de hacerlo ahora primero
vamos a ver la forma difícil y bueno sé
que a nadie le gusta escuchar esto pero
la razón es que si usamos la forma
sencilla ahorita no vamos a comprender
qué está pasando a menos que conozcamos
la forma difícil y también otra razón es
que la forma difícil tampoco es tan
difícil y la tercera razón es porque los
profesores de física muchas veces
quieren vernos resolver estos problemas
de la manera difícil por lo que debemos
saber cómo hacerlo bueno si queremos
encontrar la aceleración ustedes saben
cómo encontrarla usamos la segunda ley
de newton la aceleración en una
dirección dada es igual a la fuerza neta
en esa dirección entre la masa cuál de
estas masas vamos a elegir primero pues
podemos elegir la más grande la de cinco
kilogramos así que la aceleración en la
masa de los cinco kilogramos
es igual a la fuerza neta que actúa en
esta masa de 5 kilogramos dividida entre
estos 5 kilogramos y recuerden que
debemos elegir una dirección queremos
elegir la dirección horizontal o la
dirección vertical pues ya que esta caja
se va a acelerar de manera horizontal y
es lo que nos interesa pongo aquí una
equis para indicar que esto va a ser en
la dirección horizontal ahora puedo
sustituir valores la aceleración de la
masa de 5 kilogramos en la dirección
horizontal va a ser igual a qué fuerzas
tenemos aquí para conocer qué fuerzas
van aquí tenemos que dibujar un diagrama
de fuerzas bueno en esta masa de 5
kilogramos voy a tener la fuerza de
gravedad que va hacia abajo
fg va a haber una fuerza igual que va
hacia arriba y es la fuerza normal esta
fuerza normal es igual en magnitud a la
fuerza de gravedad
en esta caja seguramente no está siendo
acelerada verticalmente y no hay razón
para que lo esté esta mesa es rígida hay
una fuerza más en esta caja es una
fuerza que va a la derecha que será la
fuerza de tensión
y si no hay fricción en esta mesa no
tendré una fuerza que vaya hacia la
izquierda y normalmente ignoramos la
resistencia al aire así que aquí también
lo hago y eso es todo la única fuerza
horizontal que tenemos aquí este y la
divido entre la masa de los cinco
kilogramos que es de 5 kilogramos y
tenemos un problema no conocemos la
aceleración de la masa de los 5
kilogramos y tampoco conozco la tensión
no lo puedo resolver normalmente lo que
hacemos en estos casos es calcular la
otra dirección la dirección vertical
pero en este caso esto tampoco me va a
ayudar porque me dice que la fuerza
normal es igual a la fuerza de gravedad
y pues eso ya lo sabíamos realmente no
nos está ayudando qué hacemos entonces
bueno noten que esto es solo para la
masa de 5 kilogramos ahora voy a tener
que analizar la masa de 3 kilogramos lo
ponemos de este lado la aceleración de
la masa de tres kilogramos va a ser
igual a la fuerza neta en esta masa de 3
kilogramos
dividida entre la masa que es de 3
kilogramos nuevamente cual dirección
debemos elegir pues esta aceleración va
a ser vertical por lo que elijo esa
dirección aquí le pongo unas 10
para recordarme de que esto es sobre la
dirección vertical
qué fuerzas debo de poner aquí esto lo
descubrimos con nuestro diagrama de
fuerzas
tengo una fuerza de gravedad en esta
masa de 3 kilogramos y voy a tener la
misma atención que tenía en este otro
lado por lo que la atención de este lado
de la cuerda va a ser el mismo que el
que tengo en este otro lado suponiendo
que esta polea no tiene resistencia y no
tiene casi masa casi no tiene masa y no
tiene fricción en este caso a mis
tensiones van a tener el mismo tamaño y
la dibujo hacia arriba pero no va a ser
tan grande como la fuerza de gravedad al
menos en esta masa esta tensión va a ser
más pequeña y la razón es que esta masa
se está acelerando hacia abajo y las
fuerzas no se pueden balancear por lo
que la fuerza de tensión tiene que ser
más pequeña en este diagrama de fuerzas
pero esta tensión de aquí debe ser igual
a esta otra atención de acá vamos a
escribir los valores la aceleración en
la masa de tres kilogramos en la
dirección
a ser igual a mis dos fuerzas verticales
tengo la atención hacia arriba por lo
que será positiva normalmente a mi
convención es que todo lo que vaya en
dirección hacia arriba será positivo y
todo lo que vaya en dirección hacia
abajo será negativo tengo la gravedad
hacia abajo por lo que tendrá valor
negativo esto es 3 kilogramos por la
aceleración de la gravedad en la tierra
que es igual al 9.8 metros por segundo
al cuadrado y ahora todo esto lo divido
entre la masa que son 3 kilogramos
pero sigo teniendo problemas no conozco
esta aceleración y tampoco conozco esta
atención que es lo que pueda hacer bueno
si se dan cuenta aquí mis incógnitas en
este lado son la aceleración y la
atención y mis incógnitas en este otro
lado también son la aceleración y la
atención
pareciera que tengo dos ecuaciones con
dos incógnitas quizás debamos
combinarlas y eso es exactamente lo que
tenemos que hacer tengo la atención en
ambas fórmulas vamos a despejar la
atención en esta de aquí ya que es más
fácil y tenemos que no es atención es
igual a mi masa de 5 kilogramos por la
aceleración de esta masa de 5 kilogramos
en la dirección horizontal y ahora tengo
mi tensión que es igual a esto voy a
tomar esto y lo voy a sustituir en esta
otra fórmula ya que esa tensión de este
lado es la misma que la atención de este
otro lado tomo esto y lo sustituyó en
esta atención de aquí
queda que la aceleración de la masa de
los tres kilogramos en la dirección
vertical será igual y aquí arriba vamos
a tener bastantes cosas esta te es igual
a cinco kilogramos por cinco kilogramos
por la aceleración de la masa de cinco
kilogramos en la dirección horizontal y
tengo todo esto de acá así que esto lo
pongo aquí abajo y ahora que tengo pues
sigo teniendo mis tres kilogramos aquí
abajo ahí estamos mejor que antes pues
sí estamos mejor porque ahora mis únicas
incógnitas son las aceleraciones pero
éstas no son iguales esta aceleración es
la de la masa de tres kilogramos en la
dirección vertical y esta es la
aceleración de la masa de cinco
kilogramos en dirección horizontal y
aquí es donde voy a tener que dar un
argumento y a muchas personas no les
gusta esto pero es crucial para poder
resolver el problema esta idea es que
imaginen que esta masa de 3 kilogramos
se mueve hacia acá 1 metro
esta masa de 5 kilogramos se moverá
hacia adelante un metro de no ser así
entonces no proporcionaría ese metro de
cuerda que necesita esta masa para bajar
de manera que la cuerda se rompió o la
cuerda se estiró y suponemos que nuestra
cuerda ni se rompe ni se estira aunque
esto no es del todo cierto todas las
cuerdas se van a estirar un poquito
aunque sea pero en este caso vamos a
suponer que este estiramiento es muy
pequeño por lo que si esta masa de tres
kilogramos se mueve hacia abajo cierta
distancia la masa de cinco kilogramos se
tiene que mover hacia adelante la misma
distancia de manera que proporciona la
cantidad suficiente de cuerda para que
esta masa de tres kilogramos se pueda
mover hacia abajo de otras maneras
imagínense si esto no se mueve y la masa
de tres kilogramos si se mueve más
lejos que la masa de 5 kilogramos esta
cuerda o se está estirando o se está
rompiendo si no me creen vamos en el
vídeo y piensen en ello para que se
convenzan si no están convencidos de
esto no van a poder solucionar el
problema si se convencen de esto verán
que si esta masa de 3 kilogramos se está
moviendo hacia abajo con cierta
velocidad y rapidez de ciertos metros
por segundo entonces nuestra masa de 5
kilogramos también se tiene que estar
moviendo a la misma velocidad o rapidez
ya que de no ser así no estará
proporcionando la cuerda necesaria para
que la otra masa se desplace esta
cantidad
y si ustedes creen en todo esto pues no
les va a ser difícil convencerse de que
esta masa de 3 kilogramos sin importar
cuál sea su aceleración hacia abajo esta
masa de 5 kilogramos también deberá
tener la misma aceleración hacia la
derecha para que pueda dar la cuerda
necesaria para este movimiento sin que
se estire o se rompa la aceleración de
la masa de 3 kilogramos en la dirección
vertical es negativa porque va hacia
abajo y suponemos que hacia arriba es
positivo y hacia abajo es negativo esta
masa de 5 kilogramos tiene una
aceleración hacia la derecha por lo que
es positiva todo lo que va hacia la
derecha es positivo y todo lo que va
hacia la izquierda es negativo así que
el signo puede variar pero la magnitud
es la misma de manera que se dé la
suficiente cuerda que necesita la otra
masa para moverse así que aquí las
magnitudes son las mismas y aquí como
tenemos que una es negativa y otra es
positiva puedo decir
y la aceleración en la masa de tres
kilogramos en sentido vertical es igual
a menos la aceleración en la masa de
cinco kilogramos en dirección horizontal
pude verlo escrito de la otra manera
donde la masa de cinco kilogramos en x
es positiva y a la masa de tres
kilogramos en dirección vertical sea
negativa pero aquí lo importante es que
solo son diferentes en el signo y esta
es la pieza clave que necesitamos para
resolver el problema
ponemos esta ecuación final aquí en la
otra fórmula para dejar todo en términos
de una sola incógnita si tengo aquí mi
3g y aquí me dice que a 13 es igual a
menos a 5 x tomo esto y lo sustituyó
aquí me va a quedar menos a 5 x igual a
todo esto que voy a copiar y pegar y
ahora solamente tengo que despejar una
incógnita ya tengo todo en términos de a
5x aunque se encuentra en ambos lados
sólo es cuestión de combinarla ahí
en un lado por lo que solo tenemos que
usar un poco de álgebra aquí vamos a
mover esto de aquí para tener más
espacio y ahora vamos a despejar a 5x
multiplicamos ambos lados por 3
kilogramos para deshacernos de este
denominador me queda menos 3 kilogramos
a 5x y como multiplique ambos lados por
3 kilogramos de este lado sólo me queda
5 kilogramos
que multiplica a 5 en la dirección
horizontal menos 3 por 9.8 nos da menos
29.4 newtons vamos a combinar nuestros
términos con a 5 vamos a mover este
menos 3 x
5x de este otro lado sumando esto en
ambos lados y sumemos 29.4 en ambos
lados me queda a 29.4 newtons positivos
porque está del otro lado de la igualdad
esto desaparece del lado izquierdo y me
queda que sumó este término en ambos
lados de la igualdad me queda 3
kilogramos a 5x positivo desaparece de
este otro lado por lo que nos queda 5
kilogramos a 5x
3 kilogramos a 5x y desde el lado
derecho puedo combinar ambos términos ya
estamos cerca de terminarlo 5 a 3
es igual a 8 a por lo que me queda 29.4
newtons igual a 8 kilogramos por la
aceleración en la masa de 5 kilogramos
en dirección horizontal ahora a ambos
lados lo divido entre 8
y normalmente ponemos la variable que
queremos despejar del lado izquierdo y
aquí tengo 29.4 newtons entre 8
kilogramos
es igual a la aceleración en la masa de
5 kilogramos en la dirección horizontal
escribo esto en mi calculadora y
redondeado nos da 3.68 que es positivo y
esto es bueno ya que esta masa de 5
kilogramos tiene una aceleración
positiva entonces son 3 puntos 68 metros
por segundo al cuadrado positivos pero
esto es solo para la masa de 5
kilogramos cuál va a ser la aceleración
en la masa de tres kilogramos pues es
fácil va a tener la misma magnitud que
la de la masa de cinco kilogramos pero
con el signo contrario
conozco cuánto es a 5x lo sustituyó aquí
y sé que a 3 va a ser igual a esto pero
con signo negativo menos 3.68 metros por
segundo al cuadrado y con esto
terminamos ya encontramos ambas
aceleraciones la aceleración de la masa
de tres kilogramos es negativa lo cual
no nos sorprende porque es una
aceleración que va hacia abajo
y encontramos la aceleración en nuestra
masa de 5 kilogramos que es positiva lo
que también tiene sentido porque va
hacia la derecha vamos a repasar qué es
lo que hicimos primero usamos nuestra
segunda ley de newton para la masa de 5
kilogramos que no pudimos calcular
usamos la segunda ley de newton para la
masa de 3 kilogramos que tampoco pudimos
resolver y aquí se puso confuso todo
porque parecía que teníamos tres
incógnitas y solo dos ecuaciones pero la
clave que nos permitió resolver esto de
manera que sólo tuviéramos una incógnita
y una ecuación fue tener las
aceleraciones en términos de ellas
mismas y esto es porque esas
aceleraciones no son independientes las
aceleraciones deben tener la misma
magnitud y en este caso una tuvo el
signo opuesto sustituimos esto en la
otra ecuación y nos quedó una ecuación
con una incógnita despejamos esta
incógnita obtuvimos la magnitud de la
aceleración y esta es la forma difícil
de resolver este problema en el
siguiente vídeo
cuál es la forma sencilla de hacerlo